the ending of a videogame should be the
pinnacle of your experience the good
guys saves the day and usually the bad
guy meets their demise over the past 15
years games have regularly offered an
alternating giving the gamer a slightly
more fitting final scene which matches
their play style are chosen character
today we run down five grit alternate
video game endings as always watch out
for spoilers for the following
Mortal Kombat has had hundreds of
different endings over the years due to
each character have their own little
subplot when Mortal Kombat 4 came around
Jackson Sonya were tracking down a chap
named Jarek
if you complete the tournament through
Nutella to win with Sonia you receive
this acting MasterCard it's over Jarek
shinnok is dead the good guys won
you're coming back with me never Sonia I
agreed to help defeat [ __ ] on not turn
myself into the Special Forces the black
dragon live on
the black dragon died with Kano you're
the last one Jarek
pause that because if you complete the
game as Jarek the end scene continues
come in make your brakes
this is lieutenant Sonya Blade
and guess what if you complete the game
as Jax the ending continues again I'm
sorry please drop me wrong Jerry this is
not a brutality this is a fatality I
think these three went to jean-claude
Van Damme's act in school and don't
worry about Sonya she returned in the
very next game and she's still here
today we have a party waiting for you
back life force evil dictator pagan min
may look like a dancer from Gangnam
style but he is in fact a great
antagonist fighting your way through
thousands of enemies for the chance to
meet him again was thrilling and the
sandbox we are given is testament to
open-world gaming I personally spent 30
hours in Iraq before I saw the end
credits roll but what if I told you the
game could be finished in 13 minutes yes
13 minutes during the opening stages of
the game
our hero meets with min to ask if he can
place his mother's ashes alongside her
daughter began suddenly begins to
torture and presumably kill a guest at
his table so the players gut instinct is
to get out as soon as possible
everything like dinner they don't ever
teach you but if you are patient if you
sit still if you stay you are taken to
the end of the game without shooting a
single weapon back maybe dictators have
a bad name
you want me to follow Jesus Christ yes
boy the ashes aren't going to scatter
themselves
oh good you feel better now get it out
of your system
maybe now we can finally shoot some
goddamn guns
you cannot have an alternate ending
countdown without gta5 after spending
time with Michael Trevor and Franklin
it's easy to see them as a dysfunctional
family kind of like my own but by the
time the final mission comes around you
are given three choices a kill Michael B
kill Trevor
or risk everything in pixie Deathwish a
pixie ain't that a [ __ ]
studies show about 80 percent of people
pick C which means millions of people
have not played through the other
permutations killing Michael is quite
depressing and doesn't serve the
storyline in the slightest but killing
Trevor actually makes sense he's an
insane murderer who will probably kill
you at some point so by choosing this
option you take part in a car chase
before Trevor hits a gasoline truck or
petrol tanker or whatever he's calling
your country
I know it's hard to pull the trigger now
so don't worry Michael we'll do it for
you now sit back and enjoy your friend
burning to death
Silent Hill 2 was freaking scary
constant fog terrible dialogue and
terrifying enemies it was a masterpiece
there are in fact six endings which
agarwood suit the storyline but one
stands out above the rest
if your hero chooses a specific room to
enter a certain point in the game he can
meet the villain of the piece the real
villain and it said dog seriously a dog
using computer with a headset on from
being one of the most frightening games
of its time to being one of the most
ridiculous in seconds it only gets worse
when the end credits roll and instead of
an eerie track you are rewarded with a
dog barking sound let's pretend this
never happened back to the Far Cry
series for our final entry Far Cry 3 to
be more specific this game will be
forever immortalized four vows but I'll
leave talking about him for another
video it's really his sister that plays
an important part in this one in the
last few seconds of the game you are
given a choice to rescue your friends
which as you'd expect is the right thing
to do or you can kill your friends yep
that's seriously an option things get a
little more twisted when you are treated
to this sex scene moments after
murdering your own friends but that's
not the worst part
with me
I
the moral of the story don't trust a
naked chick with a knife well that's
what my dad always told me anyway so
that's it
five of the greatest alternative endings
and video games I know there are many
many many more so please let us know
your favorites in the comments below
if you've enjoyed wasting time with us
please give us a like and consider
subscribing I'll see you again next time